- And that is the story about the
one time I saw Snooki at
the Cheesecake Factory.
- Well that's wild.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh you guys.
- What.
- Our Emmy's show with
predictions, fashion and
special guests starts
in less than 30 seconds!
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Whoa, wait.
- The stage isn't ready Drew.
- And this years host is
Cedric the Entertainer
and he's waiting on us and
plus where's the audience?
- Yeah and I'm not in
the right outfit Drew.
- No.
- Okay you know what.
(magical chiming)
(audience cheering)
- Welcome, welcome, welcome!
- Hi everybody.
- Hey everybody, hey, hey, hey.
- [Drew] We are coming to you from
beautiful, sunny, Hollywood and I'm joined
by my dearest friends, it's our fellow
hosts of Entertainment Tonight,
Nischelle Turner and Kevin Frazier!
(audience cheering)
- Hi guys!
- And as usual, I got a hot date
(Audience cheering)
- Hi everybody!
(audience cheering)
- All right lets get this party started
- Lets do this
- The 73rd Emmy Awards airs this Sunday,
September 19th, on CBS.
So today we're gonna
break down the history,
- Yes
- The nominees, and of course the fashion,
- Please
- Now Kevin, this is a
stand out year in many ways,
I'd love you to explain to everyone why.
- Yeah, well its important because,
I feel like the Emmy nominations
look like the country,
and what we're watching.
46 people of color nominated.
(audience cheering)
- Yes! Yes!
- And also I look at Jean Smart for Hacks,
and also I look at
someone like Mj Rodriguez,
the first trans person nominated,
in a lead actress in a drama, category
(audience cheering)
- Phenomenal, so well deserved
- And its also, we're back, we're back.
- We're here, you're in
a tux, come on black Bond
- We're on the red carpet, lets go
- And speaking of the red carpet,
one of the main reasons
people tune in to the Emmys,
is for the fashion
(audience cheering)
- Yes indeed, yes indeed.
- Let's take a look at
some of the most iconic
Emmy fashion moments ever, take a look.
- I love this
- [Voice Over] The Emmy Awards
are one of entertainments
biggest nights in fashion,
even if you don't take home a trophy,
you can still win it, on the red carpet.
When the Emmys first
broadcast went national,
back in the 1950s,
people like Lucile Ball set the
stage for fashion standards.
In the 60s, people saw a lot
of peace, love and flower power
and the 80s were all about the hair.
By the time the 90s rolled around
it was about the whole package.
Designer dress, jewelry,
shoes, you name it.
Go bo ma or go home.
In 2002, designer Bradley Bayou
was ready to quit the business,
when he got a phone call,
from the Queen of Daytime,
herself, Oprah Winfrey.
Who wore one of his designs
to accept the first ever
Bob Hope humanitarian award.
And because the Emmys honor television,
if you're on a popular series,
you get to come back,
year after year, after year.
But there's one actress who's
graced the Emmy's red carpet
for over 6 decades, Betty
White is in fact older
than the Emmys itself, and yet,
she never shys away from a good sparkle.
Recently a new class of TV personalities
have taken red carpet
style to a whole new level.
Embracing personality,
authenticity and risk taking.
And I personally love it.
In 2019, Billie Porter
awed in a disco inspired,
Michael Kors suit, topped
with an a-symmetrical
custom hat, by British
designer, Stephen Jones.
While last year Zendaya's quick change
from Christopher John Rodgers,
to Selena Quintanilla inspired
Giorgio Armani Privé look,
landed her on every best dresses list.
We can't wait to see who wears
what on the next red carpet.
(audience cheering)
- Do you guys miss the red carpet?
Like I miss the red carpet.
- Are you kidding me?
- I know
- That's our bread and butter,
I cannot tell you how I am
ready for a fashion moment.
- Thank you
- So ready for a fashion moment
- So what are we gonna look for,
what are the trends gonna be this year?
- I tell you what they will be,
no hoodies, no pajamas,
there won't be that.
- Jason Sudeikis might trick us though,
he might show up in a hoodie
- You think he might show up in a hoodie,
to promote his sister's company.
- Maybe, maybe, could be
- I wouldn't mind that
- I do think you'll see
more color from the men,
I think that you'll see more,
I mean whatever Billie Porter
wears is going to be fantastic
You know he's gonna come fab.
He'll have a moment
- But there will be other
people that give us a moment,
I mean we saw Tracee
Ellis Ross, in that piece.
She's gonna give us a moment,
she's nominated for lead
actress in a comedy,
and she does fashion, for me,
like no one on the red carpet right now
(audience cheering)
- She brings it
- She's very fashion forward,
so she does give a moment.
I think that we're gonna see
Kaley Cuoco give us a moment,
because she gave us a princess
moment when we were at home,
and she was nominated for the first time,
but we know she's going
through a transition,
just announced her divorce,
the first time we're
gonna see her after that,
I think she's gonna
give us a, revenge body,
here I am, see me love me, moment.
- Let em know Kale, let em know
- I think she's going to
- Well sometimes I have to say,
that you have got to go out there,
and dress with your heart,
and all of your spirit,
and not worry about what
someone is gonna say about it.
- Yes, wear the red platform heel
- Absolutely! Wear the heel!
(audience cheering)
- Peewee Herman called,
he wants his shoes back.
(upbeat music)